what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop them
when you're thinking i'm about to do
something that could break the universe
i know you run it by us
we need to send them back
you're not gonna take this away from me
you're flying out into the darkness to
fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting spider-man i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another way there it
isn't
spider-man no way home december 17th i
underestimated you peter do i know you
looks like we got competition
we started getting some visitors
in their universe they all die fighting
spider-man i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another win there isn't
what's happening they're starting to
come through i can't stop him
spider-man no way home exclusively at
movie theaters december 17th
you're not peter parker i am so confused
right now
that spell that you bought started
pulling in visitors from every universe
the multiverse is real
[Applause]
they all die fighting spider-man there
has to be another way there isn't
they're a danger to our universe
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
spiderman no way home in theaters
december 17th ever since i got bit by
that spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal that was when you found
out peter
that spell that you botched it started
pulling in visitors from every universe
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop him
spider-man no way home when you're
thinking hey i'm about to do something
that could break the universe run it by
us next time in theaters december 17th
this is peter leave a message yeah peter
this is happy
who are those guys huh
one of the guys made a mud what's going
on call me back
when i shut that spell down we started
getting some visitors from every
universe
multiverse is real
was that a dinosaur
in theaters december 17th
you